rating for the amendment and uh but what
we'll do in the meantime is have the
sponsor tell us what we'll see when we
get
it thank you very much Mr chairman um
I'm very thankful that they actually got
the amendment drafted before we begun
and began and uh they're busy killing
trees upstairs so we can read the actual
document I provided you all with an
amendment summary and the language that
I submitted to OS so that you can see
what the changes are um so as bit of a
history um last week we were here and
there was the idea of do we try and get
closer to what will be an actual
passable bill that fits the needs of all
the stakeholders and everybody involved
in this process so with that um I spoke
with a few of the Senators who were very
involved in this and um I spoke to
others trying to figure out where we can
make our bill closer to something that
would get broad support in the Senate um
there's quite a few changes within here
um and um I can run through those uh the
first part that I did is we all working
from the governor's list of list for
what would be needed in a bill that he
would not veto because that is the
framework that we're all working through
um I added into the purpose and finding
a section on that and how this bill
addresses those needs because sometimes
it's a little bit unclear um our
reduction to poly drugs is um the fact
fact that we're introducing 15 stores at
first and making sure that we can
increase those stores in the future if
we find that people in some regions of
the state are only accessing thank you
only accessing illicit cannabis because
that is not the harm reduction that's
intended by the governor so having that
within our our expectations for in the
future evaluating the number of stores
is a good way to make sure that we meet
that stated goal of the governor to
reduce access to illicit Market cannabis
Ted tainted by Fentanyl and to reduce
the other harms that come from
that um we also speak he had also wanted
to have a ban on lobbying and donations
and that one is problematic um but I
believe that the core of that is that if
we set up a program where only a select
few are able to participate in the
market and if that process isn't
transparent then the potential and the
concern that people may not think that
things are on the up and up is so high
that I assume that that's why he wants
to have the limitation on the lobbying
IND donations so to address that by
doing it instead of a franchise model
but a highly regulated and transparent
process we're able to remove some of
that squish factor from decisions where
um in the ru making the Liquor
Commission will lay out what they're
looking for and how they're judging
people so that people know ahead of time
and they have a process where people can
have transparency about
you know who understood the assignment
and who was able to deliver and in a
limited market I think that's what we
should move for those people who can
actually fit the requirements of the
program and also making sure that the
laws and administrative rules don't pick
favorites but have that transparent
process I think really eliminates that
concern um that is well founded when
only 15 people potentially only three
with the commission language that says
15 stores owning up to five of them if
you had people who are operating the
entire Market that's uh a concerning
situation and I understand why under
that Paradigm there would be a reason to
not have lobbying or contributions so
let's just do a better
Paradigm um there were quite a few
sections and the definitions where I
went through a lot of those details and
Nuance with Senator abbis and we figured
out where he had a better definition or
he liked mine um that's in the back of
it you guys can peruse that at some
point or just
trust that any mistakes will get fixed
in the
future another section that has been a
big deal breaker for some is the idea of
a dual use license the Dual use was laid
out as a store that was overseen both by
The Liquor Commission and by the
Department of Health and Human Services
in order to be a hybrid store and
alternative treatment center retail
location um this whole framework allows
retail outlets to sell therapeutic
cannabis and since retail outlets can
sell therapeutic cannabis sourced
through the
atcs um the need for specific separate
license it would only be necessary if we
otherwise wouldn't allow the atcs to
participate um instead of giving a
guarantee we need to ensure that they
can compete for these and that one of
the factors that's recognized in the
application process is that if somebody
has operated a successful uh alternative
treatment center in the state that that
should be one of the factors under
consideration that only the atcs who
have been operating will be able to meet
that so it'll be one extra extra little
tally in their court because they've
been here they've done this Market they
provided access to our patients but it
won't be the only deciding factor which
provides transparency and is fair
because you also you know we have great
operators here but you still want to you
still want to set it up in language that
makes it clear that you can't just come
in with the absolute minimal minimal
deliverable product you need to actually
be offering a good service to the people
of New Hampshire so that guarantees that
they're going to be just as sharp with
their pencil setting up their strategy
as anybody
else no I still have some more but let's
go through if there's questions on the
topics okay we we if you want to do that
we'll ask at the end um then there is
also a big concern about the law
enforcement prohibition
um that one was a deal breaker for one
of the Senators because he was concerned
about Blue on Blue if uh the federal
government was coming in and raiding
somewhere in swat unmarked and somebody
reported a home invasion local police
respond and then suddenly you have local
police having um a a shootout with the
federal government so the idea of not
notifying law enforcement I have removed
from the bill I know it seems like a
stretch but these days with swatting
attacks you never know so let's make
sure that this bill the way that it's
amended would make it so that law
enforcement at the St state or local
level won't exp expending resources to
pursue cannabis as a federal crime as
long as it's consistent with our laws
but it does allow them to talk to the
federal government if the feds do decide
to pursue this and quite frankly if the
feds feds tell them that they're coming
in and pursuing this it would be nice
for them to know because maybe they can
let everybody involved know hold on the
whole situation has changed and now the
federal government is enforcing this if
you want to get out probably now is a
good time to get out of this business
and this market so that communication I
think should be
preserved um next comes the smoking in
public one of the highly contentious
issues um in the bill we did not have a
misdemeanor but we've come to a
compromise that the first offense is a
violation and you forfeit all the
Cannabis and cannabis products on your
person not in your car if you've just
gone and purchased it not in in your
house but what you're physically in
possession of because if you're out and
smoking it in public you know there's a
lot of people that have a really big
problem with that um and I understand
that I'm not a cigarette smoker so I
don't like that either but I uh it's
just one of those ideas of being a nice
respectful neighbor on the second
offense within five years it would be a
fine up to $500 in the forfeiture of the
Cannabis and products on your person and
then um after two or more prior
convictions within three five years it
becomes a misdemeanor um I had really
been looking at the Class B misdemeanor
and then the issue was raised that what
about somebody who's on her fifth sixth
or seventh smoking in public violation
at that point if somebody's really
flagrant about it and they just don't
care it would make sense that if
somebody just keeps flagrantly violating
our law and getting caught then maybe
some jail time should be on the table so
that's why it's not designated as a
Class B um it's a non-starter over in
the Senate if we don't have it is just a
misdemeanor as opposed to a class B so
um that's a compromise that I've made
and speaking with stakeholders um it
seems to be acceptable to
them there's a couple other details that
probably are a little bit too far into
the weeds and discussing it with the
Senators but um as turning to the next
page where I have my nine and 10 and my
numbering wasn't great a lot of that is
just moving the Dual use out but the
language instead of guaranteeing the ATC
as a store would now say providing that
a major criteria in assessing the
relative merits of each application will
incorporate the successful operation of
an alternative treatment center
registered under RSA
126x and may convert to a cannabis
retail outlet for sales permitted under
this chapter and RSA 126x so that makes
it clear that the intention is that they
can continue that they can offer both
when they if they do get a retail outlet
and open that um another one too reading
through the governor's list
he seems very strong on the 15 while
also being pretty strong on the idea
that the whole point of this is harm
reduction not profits and to make sure
that the illicit Market is a lot less
attractive because unfortunately we have
people in our state dying because
they're buying cannabis on the street
that's been contaminated with fentanyl
um since that is one of the overarching
goals in passing this legislation um in
the section talking about increasing the
number of stores um I added the words
increase that one of the reasons to
increase the number of stores is to
increase access to Legal cannabis in New
Hampshire for people throughout the
state this is so that if the first 15
stores just pop up in the Southern Tier
that there might be a reason to make
sure that people in the North Country
aren't left to cross a border or turn to
the streets because we want to make sure
that harm reduction isn't just for those
people and highly populated areas but
for gramit Staters
throughout see also so there was
something that everybody had
overlooked everywhere you have to be 21
years of age or older to go into a
cannabis store that was nowhere in any
of the versions of the bill because
we're also going to be having access for
um therapeutic cannabis um I replaced
the entire section that was about dual
use with entry to cannabis retail
outlets limited entry to cannabis retail
outlet shall be restricted to people to
21 years of age or older Who present
documentation consistent with that
section and qualifying patients that way
there's access for patients if they have
a a retail outlet closer and they don't
want to go to an ATC location if those
are still operating then they can get
that access but otherwise you're not
going to have people under 21 in those
stores because we shouldn't have people
under 21 in those
stores and then a couple things about
the municipal so that it's a municipal
election and so the bienal so we're not
bringing a whole C cost making sure the
municipality needs to actually tell the
commission that the application meets
the local requirements and adding that
into the whole process for application
approval and then finally in
Appropriations um the 2 million that we
had in there looking at every other
version is probably not enough 8 million
was the seconde amount in what passed
through Ways and Means last year so the
appropriation for administration of this
chapter is now $8 million
and the allocation of funds has also
been changed um apparently a lot of
people don't want their pensions paid
for by pot and since since we've been
talking about all these different issues
of try of tying in um just trying to
make sure that we're not creating new
problems with the federal government
having that be the primary primary place
that money goes doesn't really make
sense um as I was balancing this I
looked at to House Bill 639 that passed
the house last year I looked at what
Senator abbis had proposed um within
that passing the house had 15% going to
um the pensions abbis has 20% going to
the pensions so I did keep 15% going to
the pensions just because it's such a
large unfunded liability but I'd be
willing to send that to education if you
prefer to just keep pensions out of it
entirely then uh 10% goes to the
Community reinvestment Fund so that one
is largely providing water and sewer
access because Water and Sewer access is
one of the big limitations for new
housing Construction in the state and
rather than rather than that would be a
good way to make sure that we can have
some of that infrastructure that will
help make more affordable housing it
also would allow for some legal aid for
people that are seeking annulments and
whatnot so it's just kind of a nice way
to make sure that some of this money
goes back to the community in specific
areas then uh 10% to the substance use
prevention treatment and Recovery Fund
that's created in this act 5% of
broad-based Aid to the municipalities
that have a retail store um so this is
one that had had a little bit of push
back when I was speaking with the
Senators but um in their model they had
a 15% uh fee excise tax fee whichever
whatever you want to call it with 1% of
that going to the municipality by doing
that that's actually 6 and
23% so they already had that same
intention of making sure that those
communities who did Step Up in order to
have these stores have a little bit more
money to handle potentially traffic
issues or anything else that's around
there um and this is something that's
been consistent in several of the bills
then 5% um without a cap as had been in
the bill previously to public safety
agent agencies having more drug
recognition experts um so that people
can actually when driving Intoxicated by
cannabis and Other Drugs including
medications is a big net positive for
our society the only substance that has
a per se limit that if you violate a
tested limit is alcohol but there are
people that drive impaired from all
sorts of substances from cocaine to
methamphetamine to cannabis to Benadryl
so having more drug drug recognition
help experts will help all of us well
all of us who uh don't make those
terrible decisions I should say and then
5% it wasn't in this bill but it's been
every other B every other version says
that 5% goes for Behavioral Health on
the children's Behavioral Health so that
would deal with the kids that are
getting boarded in emergency rooms and
not getting the mental health care that
they need and when we're not sending as
much to the pensions it makes sense to
loop back that back in So this brings it
back significantly to um what had
already passed through Ways and Means
last year so that we have a more
consistent view um this gets as close to
um gets as close to everything that I
had in the discussions with Senator
abbis and Senator Lang although it does
not have the franchise model um I'm I
remain concerned that a franchise model
doesn't have the transparency that we
need for public trust and I think that
when we set up a system like this public
trust is the most important thing that
we need to keep because public trust
Public Safety and making sure that there
is accountability and then nobody's
wondering why a particular operator got
the got the um license I think is going
to make sure that people just look at
this as a new market that's opening up
instead of a less favorable view so I
think we've actually made phenomenal
progress here you know looking back and
seeing all of these metrics I I didn't
quite appreciate just how many changes
we made I think that they make it better
um obviously there's a couple
compromises where we could have gone one
way or the other but I think this is now
an excellent bill that I hope will have
you know strong support of everybody who
believes in any sort of um legalization
cannabis and to move forward with a very
strong
Bill okay now represent
spear I I just wanted a clarification so
the ATC uh the therapeutic Cannabis
stores that exist now they would still
exist they don't get folded into this
unless we do something as you described
in the uh in the change that you made um
so there's been nothing that would close
those stores um I don't see anything
within this law or anything else that
would close those stores um one of the
big questions would what has been about
whether or not they'd want to convert
those stores to a retail outlet um some
people think that they wouldn't because
they may or may not be in the best
locations um they may actually be
interested in doing that and competing
either in the same store or elsewhere
but if they have to compete on equal
footing to get one of the the outlet
licenses um I think that the choice of
location is just part of that
application
process representative burough is
next
thanks for taking my question and um I
apologize I don't think you addressed
this and I'm going to use a phrase I
really hate but um it says that the
atc's um must be considered a successful
operation should be considered a major
factor what is that major factor and how
do we give it suspenders that's the
phrase I hate uh thank you that's a
really good question and that's one of
those parts that would come up in
administrative rules um and so then we
need to make sure that we express what
that legislative intent is I mean how
much of a factor do we think that that
should have I know that in a tie a tie
should go to the ATC but beyond that tie
how much more of a boost should it get
and I think that that's a good
discussion and one that probably should
happen in public hearings with full
transparency in the process of rul
making just because it's hard to know
until the entire rubric is set
out okay representative Gibbs thank you
uh how have the uh representatives of
the current atc's responded to this
proposed change to the bill um thank you
I I had sent some proposed language
previously about how I was working
towards it to try and get the best
language um I actually sent the email to
them with a specific language and then
drove up here so I haven't looked at my
email to see specifically what they say
but I do know that there are some of
them here yes we can certainly invite
them up to
speak any other
questions okay don't go far I will thank
you okay anyone in the at want to speak
for the atc's and where they are with
this
amendment there we
go thank you Mr
chairman for the record Matt Simon
Granite Leaf
cannabis so I did just receive this
amendment when you did and have skimmed
it not read it thoroughly
um I think there are two sets of
comments I'd like to make and first of
all I'd like to thank the sponsor for
her hard work in putting this together
I'd like to thank everybody who's
patiently participated in this process
trying to get us to a workable
compromise I think there are two sets of
issues here that often get lumped
together in this one is what happens to
the atcs which are three cannabis
companies that exist in New Hampshire
that have been operating for more than
seven
years
uh this bill creates
uh criteria that would cause the atcs to
likely be able to get a retail license
and uh speaking from for granite Leaf
cannabis only I can't speak for the
others we support that concept uh we're
willing to work with that um there is
another set of questions and concerns
what happens to the therapeutic cannabis
program which now serves more than
14,000
patients when we say every adult use
store can also serve patients I think
that's very different than saying every
store is going to be a dual use
facility atcs exist to serve patients
that's our mission we're required to do
it by law we're required to provide
educational and support
services
and just gaming this out say we apply
for these retail license we receive it
we build a fancy new building which I
think we're willing to do
uh comply with every aspect of the new
program assuming that this rolls out
successfully we know that there will be
a
substantial plummeting in the number of
patient
registrations and uh sales at the atc's
in Vermont they just finished one year
of retail sales 50% reduction in patient
registrations roughly the same I'm
assuming for total number of sales in
that case it wasn't catastrophic for for
the the businesses because they all had
graded licenses and were already able to
expand to serve adults so the fact that
their medical business
suffered wasn't too harmful for them but
Vermont is now trying to figure out how
to actually restore these Services uh so
that the patients who are getting their
cannabis from adult youth stores do
receive education and support so I'm
confident that can be done my concern is
that by not allowing the Dual use
language and and it's not here so I
can't refer to it but the Dual use
language was more
about requiring that patients continue
to receive
Service uh requiring that atc's don't
just drop the medical thing and start
serving adults and trying to make as
much money as possible rather than
producing the wide range of products we
currently produce and operating the way
we current operate so my concern is that
about a year after adult use stor are
open that all of the ATC Medical Only
dispensaries will shut down are we
expected to continue operating them
after they become money losers I'm
concerned that we're setting up
incentives that
steer uh in the direction of shutting
down the medical program and just
treating cannabis Like Liquor those are
my comments I'm not saying I'm for or
against anything or telling anybody what
to do on the ATC subject we have three
different companies that can weigh in
for themselves I I do think it would
make sense to hear from the Department
of Health and Human Services which
administers the therapeutic cannabis
program because that's an important
policy Choice do we care about
maintaining a healthy therapeutic
cannabis program uh or do we care about
making sure that the three companies
have a path forward I care about both
things and uh that's where I currently
am with this so so if I understand
correctly if we remove the dual use the
atcs continue as they are which is they
won't have to pay a tax or collect a tax
oh excuse me fee right because if you
were operating under this new license
there is a 10% call what you
want
collection yes Mr chairman in Vermont
that's a 20% tax and that incentive did
not stop a 50% reduction in one year in
the patients so that
it uh so this people weren't driven by
the medical because the was were they
not the that 20% difference that was not
a marginal num I guess we're saying is
that the to have one close by was more
important than paying that 20% fee I
believe that was a major factor I've
also heard anecdotic excuse me
anecdotally that some adult use
businesses are essentially paying the
taxes for patients as a work around
because they want their business or in
some cases they believe in serving
patients so i' I've heard of that
happening in Maine and Vermont where
companies will just sort of voluntarily
eat the tax or pay it for patient
transactions
interesting
okay uh thank you for T taking my
question what happens to the nonprofit
status that you now have with the
atc's this bill includes an opportunity
to convert to
for-profit that's good
right that's what you wanted yes Mr
chairman not necessarily what I what I
wanted but that was what you
wanted okay yes represent thanks for
taking my question can you tell me what
what is the value add for let's say a
patient who goes to the um to one of
your fac facilities versus now getting
it from a retail what are they getting
from you that's important for them as a
patient so any patient who comes for the
first time uh we offer and recommend
that they set up a consultation with one
of our patient Educators we have a staff
member at both of our facilities whose
primary job it is to sit down with
patients many patients have never tried
cannabis before or they've tried it many
years ago and have now been recommended
to to do it by a doctor they have no
idea where to begin they they don't know
about the different types of products
how they're administered what the pros
and cons of one product versus another
might be so we sit with them and ask
them questions like what is your
previous experience with cannabis what
symptoms are you trying to manage what
other medications are you on they're
trained to know about interactions so if
they're already on medication that would
be
problematic um you know some people have
been using cannabis for a long time and
and don't need or want that kind of
education but for the subset of the
population that we that that we deal
with it's it's I think we've reduced a
lot of harm if I may invoke that harm
reduction phrase I I I was very
encouraged to hear the governor mention
harm reduction so many times in his
statement that's my view of cannabis
regulation and medical cannabis
specifically is that it is primarily a
harm reduction program and should be
guided by those principles principles
and I don't see how diminishing the
therapeutic cannabis program is
consistent with a harm reduction
approach to cannabis so I'd like to find
a way to keep our program intact if
there's a way to do that while also
reaching a
compromise okay thank you very
much is there anybody else who would
like to weigh in otherwise we'll be oh
yes
yeah make sure you hit the mic here
thank you very much chairman um uh my
name is Devon chaffy I'm the executive
director of the ACLU of New Hampshire um
and I'll be fairly brief uh I want to
thank representative Leon for all of her
persistent work on this current draft um
I think I have one uh significant
concern um with the current draft um and
similar to a concern that I had with the
previous draft that you saw at the last
work session last week and that is the
idea that people will under this draft
potentially be facing jail time for
smoking small amounts of marijuana in
public um that is actually a much
harsher uh penalty than we currently
have so if you have less than 3/4 uh
ounces currently in public and you are
smoking in public under existing law um
the most significant uh uh potential
penalty that you would face would be a
Class B misdemeanor one of the other
benefits of of categorizing it is a
Class B misdemeanor you know it's it's
still pot it's still on someone's record
it's still a a significant penalty um
but you're not facing jail time which
also means that the taxpayers of New
Hampshire aren't potentially paying for
public defenders to represent people who
were simply caught smoking in public um
I think from um a uh just a fairness and
a Justice lens and from what we're
trying to accomplish with this
legislation the idea that we would be
criminalizing um you know nonviolent
activity that right now is not
criminalized through passage of the
marijuana legalization law in a way that
would have much stiffer penalties than
currently exist and potentially putting
people in jail simply for smoking and
possessing very small amounts of
marijuana I think does not make sense um
and so that's that's one area in this
draft that I have concerns with
thank so but that that's the third
offense right within fiveyear period
correct so given that and I've talked to
our County district attorney and he told
me nobody pursues a case they just they
don't bother so third offense means that
there was district attorneys that were
willing to pursue it not once not
twice but three times times so isn't
that kind of saying that this person is
really almost intentionally trying to
flaunt the law at that
point I think that the penalty for this
particular crime um uh needs to be
commensurate with the seriousness of the
offense this is not a property crime
this is not a violent crime this is not
a crime that's an endangering other fol
FKS um there are many things for which
uh that are violations of the law for
which you might face a fine for which we
do not believe that somebody should in
fact go to jail no matter how many times
they potentially May violate the law in
my humble opinion um this offense is one
of them it should be treated instead
like say uh you know you can't go to
jail for instance for for smoking in a
um you know in a in in an indoors you
know there are violations for that but
that isn't a criminal offense for which
you could potentially see jail time that
the severity of that offense regardless
of how many times that person has
potentially offended seems not
commensurate with the offense to me
let's compare it to drunk
driving may may I so I just want to say
that if you're going to go down the
thing say marijuana is not as bad as
alcohol that you think it's okay that
people smoke pot while they're driving a
car um with all due respect uh chairman
I believe that that is a separate part
of the bill that addresses the issue
that is a a very talk about we we if you
have a third DWI you go to jail well yes
sir as you so what how's that any
difference in three three times being
busted smoking marijuana while you're
driving and in my opinion um it is it is
very different in that by drunk driving
you are putting people's lives and
health and safety at risk when you take
to the wheel when you are intoxicated
you are potentially putting people's uh
life's at risk by smoking in public that
is not at all we're talking about third
time that could be in the car that third
three times you that is a different
section of the bill chairman that
actually deals with in I just using an
example of how they might have gotten
arrested okay and that I was saying is
why you know in terms of uh three times
of uh drinking p in
public uh I bet you we that's
potentially a Class B also Class A I
know I think three times if you you know
I mean that's just how is this any
different than alcohol and the alcohol
laws if this mirrors what we do with
alcohol then I don't I don't understand
where you're going with it no um I I
don't I don't know whether or not it
mirrors a public drinking ordinance I
would be happy to investigate that for
you and and get you your answers on that
well and I think that's a much more
comparable law would be drinking in
public as opposed to exactly drinking in
public because there are plenty of
communities that ban you know alcohol
consumption in public but I was just
using cars an example because that's
where most people drunk driving or
drunks that's where most of them are
arrested is in cars representative
Sullivan we haven't heard from you
yet I wasn't trying to talk but uh to
your point what you were saying I I I I
agree with her that your analogy with
smoking and driving is different than
smoking in public I think that that's
what she was saying I think she did a
good job of explaining it I think if
you're going to do drunk
driving and smoking in driving that's
there are analogies there and then
there's analogies with how we treat
drinking in parks and smoking in parks
and that's what we should look at but
don't try toate the I would be no doubt
on my mind I mean I I mean I I can't say
what what goes on in New Hampshire or in
Hampton Beach but I know you know we're
my summer home in Rhode Island yeah you
you can potentially go to jail for your
first time being caught drinking on the
the public beach the State
Beach so I don't know what what the New
Hampshire law is so but anyways let's
have a conversation where what do people
feel about this amendment and we'll
start with you
Jared um I think that we've done a
pretty good job coming up with
compromises that
hopefully you know make people get
everybody gets a little bit and gave up
a lot feels like um do I love it no but
I think if I prioritize the things that
are most important to me it is the harm
reduction of people who consume it and
right now maybe you're getting it from a
legal sources that have fentanyl or
other things Lac into it and then also
the arresting of people and ruining
their lives because they're in caught
they're caught in possession of it or
whatever so those are the top priorities
for me I think it's no secret to this
committee and many people that I not a
fan of the state run model I think it's
an inefficient way to do it and I think
it's going to be something that gener
Generations from now people are going to
be frustrated with in the way that uh
We've structured it today and this is
our one time to get it right but am I
willing to swallow that bitter pill to
reduce the harm reduction I am and
hoping that maybe maybe at some point in
the future maybe another bot another uh
group of people sitting in this room in
a decade or what election will be coming
up before this bill will ever go into
effect so well well and and I'm I'm
saying it's probably going to be you
know years from now when that would
happen hopefully these things get
addressed but um I think it's it's
unfortunate that we don't have people
who are and I'll just kind of say this
publicly I think it's unfortunate that
we have so many people in this state who
are unwilling to um get away from the
fear of it and so that we has to be so
restricted to the point that there is
the potential that that the elicit
Market isn't wiped out because we have
only 15 stores or we have a state-run
model where the door opens for
corruption despite I think
representative Lyon's best attempts I
think that the door is still open for
corruption particularly as people get
those first licenses and when new
licenses become proposed they want that
moat to protect their business and I
think the language does its best it it
can I had suggested uh automatic numbers
of licenses being released I was told
that was probably not sellable in the in
the Senate which is unfortunate um
there's also the anchoring concerns we
discussed last time which I thought were
valid um but I think this model does
does nothing or canot totally eliminate
the idea that we're going to allow the
industry to capture the benefits of this
and I think we should we should be aware
of that and the people who are so
opposed to a more free market approach
should understand the consequences of
their what I would call stubborn Ness on
this issue and so uh that's where I
stand but I will I will swallow the
bitter pill and support this bill
because I think the benefits outweigh
the cost but I think uh it's it is hard
for me to swallow and I might share this
on I might share this little monologue
that I just shared with you all on the
floor I haven't decided yet but I might
just kind of say
that maybe representative brose thinks
that's a bad idea okay representative
spear you're next because you're
replacing Representative Vincent today
yeah I seem to do that a lot uh
thanks um I think it's it's it's a far
cry from what we started with last year
which I really liked and which would
pass which passed the house
overwhelmingly so it's in that way it's
a little disappointing it still has the
annulment feature in it which I
considered very
important uh the Dual use I understand
what we're doing and so I'm okay I guess
there might be a way to make that
workable I
hope I being a of a business mind has
anybody ever done an analysis to see if
you put out 15 stores now remember we're
being competed against all around us on
all sides of our state will 15 stores
even make this thing survive as a first
shot when we have competition everywhere
I don't know I have my doubts as to
whether or not this will even survive
the theory is that that the 10% fee is
half of what our competitor elds to
other states around us are but like it
was pointed out to us uh some people
don't care about that some people will
say all right if I can drive five
minutes and go to tsoro I'm going to do
that because it's going to save me how
much in gas if I have to go you know
however many miles away sometimes the
convenience of it is much more important
than saving a couple of dollars so I
wonder if we'll live okay representative
burough is next thanks I just I want to
go back to what um Miss chaffy said from
the ACLU that really stuck with me um
when she testified that this is our
window to get this done and while it's
not 100% of what anybody wants we're
taking a crapshoot if we don't pass it
this year we don't know we don't know
who's coming into the governor's office
we don't know who's going to be um I
know what you think who's going to be in
the majority who going to be in this
chair who's going to be in that chair
right um I know what I think but um I
think it'd be a crapshoot not to pass
this um it could be 2 years four years 6
years 8 years and how many more times
are we going to go through this it's
it's like Groundhog's Day so I think
representative Leon did an amazing job
of you know look listening to everybody
and and compromising on things that it's
as close it's as close as we're going to
get to uh a a bill that everyone can
agree on
okay
Rees I'm just worried about um uh the
licenses um going to casino
owners um I don't know I it's not going
to be in the Bill maybe it can be in the
rules I'm not quite sure but I'm I have
my doubts about it's kind of
discriminatory isn't it I live in
Manchester discrimination okay in
Manchester and no I don't I
mean I don't like casinos and I don't
trust the owners of the casinos and let
that be known that's it okay but the
Bill thank you um representative I think
you did a great job um all the way
through thanks for your
patience okay representative
pusc thank you Mr
chair
um this is the third cannabis bill I
have seen in the
last three
years two years uh the first two
cannabis Bills take up a 4 in binder in
my office with all the Amendments all
the changes all the
updates uh so far uh this bill has only
taken up
about an inch and a half in a three-inch
binder maybe that's
success
um I can and will support this
bill uh it's taken a lot for me and a
lot of thought uh and a lot of
changes because initially I would never
ever vote to pass a cannabis bill I'm a
Vietnam veteran I've seen what happened
back in the day when guys would get
stoned at night go out on the patrol the
next day day and wind up with a bullet
in their
head if that doesn't scare living crap
out of you nothing
does but I've changed even though the
Cannabis today is like 80 times more
strong than what we had in the
70s I will be supporting this build
because so far this is the best thing
I've seen and it makes its way over on
the other side of the wall and it gives
the folks over there a good starting
point to work
with and that's it for
now okay so representative post we're
still waiting for her she's I guess
she's
testifying uh representative Walsh is
next thank you Mr
chairman uh I appreciate all the hours
of work that everyone has put into this
Bill and there are indeed uh very good
changes and improvements in it however
it doesn't change the fact that it is
still illegal
federally and to make that could be just
this week you know that could supposed
to change this week oh well it it is
right now so it's it's going to
definitely affect my vote right now this
minute uh so therefore by having the
state run it it essentially makes the
state into a drug dealer in my opinion
and uh so for that reason I would
continue to be a no vote and I love
Groundhog
Day yes represent
Gibbs thank you um this bill has several
bitter pills for me as well um I would
have much preferred the free market
approach as several other um members of
the committee have
discussed but uh my main goal with
regard to can cannabis bills and I've
seen quite a few as well uh is to stop
um uh subjecting people to criminal
prosecution for marijuana and to stop uh
giving people criminal records for
marijuana uh and as my main goal and I
think rep representative L has done a
wonderful job um in finding uh
compromises that will satisfy the
largest numbers of people and I really
thank her uh so I also will support this
bill okay um so that leaves me and um I
will be supporting this bill and I would
be supporting it on the atttention is
that uh we are so far away from when
we're actually going to be selling
marijuana in the state of New Hampshire
and that I want to get the ball
rolling and not that that the term
rolling has other implications but I I
truly believe that that um the concept
whether we have you know State Stores or
franchises or agency stores or the free
market
um the the problem of the free market is
that if you don't have controls over it
like Maine um it it really is it it's
seemingly totally out of control over in
that state but having said that I'm what
I do acutely am aware of is that you
before you can even have a stores you've
got to have cultivators that have grown
it and that ain't happening for over a
year to make to make that happen
probably two years
so at that case that will be at least
one
election so that we can have plenty of
chance to revisit any of these things um
and so therefore it's at least make take
that first baby step to get forward is
uh is is passing this this legislation
and that's why why I will support
it okay so uh who would like to make a
motion all right representative
Burrows um I'd like to move are we to
pass on the amendment yeah this is for
the subcommittee okay I'd like to move
that we um pass this amendment in the
subcommittee today okay to pass on the
amendment
no well I see yeah you're right you're
right
okay and the amendment number
is 55 06 6 55h okay
okay who second it who would like to
Second it
okay all right any discussion on the
motion ought to pass on the amendment
seeing none the U all those in favor
please raise your
hand one two three four five six Al
those suppos
closed 6 to
one okay the motion is now out to pass
as
amended okay burrow and
buum I would like to um I would like to
move that we um we we pass this the pass
we passed 1633 with the amendment 0655
h okay the motion's been made in
second any question on the motion seeing
none all those in favor please raise
your
hand and all those supposed so vote is
six to
one and uh we will be taking this up
tomorrow
afternoon after lunch be taking this
bill up all right good now we can move
on to all the other liquor bills that we
have in this committee so I ask all
those who are not interested in this
rest please leave as quietly as
stealthly as you
can all
right 11:35 relative to the definition
of a specialty
beer may I make a motion Mr
chairman uh would no oh I want to look
at I want to talk about it
first
that turn what turnic
oh
I all right so which bill is this one I
I can't seem to find it it's and what's
this one about as a co-sponsor I think
we just wanted to kill
it I I can read the title guys so this
is the one that we're trying to change
uh the the language was incorrect
and after discussion we even the sponsor
and I'm a co-sponsor we decided we
should just itl it but basically the
idea was to try to
make the language did the opposite of
what what the goal was which was to try
to make more specialty beers regular
beers but I kind of did the reverse the
way it was written and it turns out it
was
maybe not the problem we thought it was
okay so this is one of the bills that I
was I I missed that day is
that um is this maybe maybe a maybe
representative Aon was running the show
at that time yeah yeah okay yeah all
right so this bill
um so you're you're you want to just
kill this then yeah should itl I know
the sponsor is fine with that okay is
anybody in the room have a problem with
iing this bill speak now your peace
okay representative Sullivan he's a
member of the
subcommittee second by representative
hunt killing a bill you know I love to
put my name
on okay right any discussion on
inexpedient to
legislate me has left the room all those
in favor say I one two three four five
Riv
walls six okay six to
zip yeah need it okay
great you know what I need it
yeah
okay you have the bills I have yeah okay
so next is
1321 repealing the penalties for the
sale of cakes of Malt Beverages without
ARR
seat all
right my my
iPad I know but I I just wonder why I'm
not not cooperating but okay
[Music]
uh so to the commission is there
anything is this okay this bill as it is
just fine um and I can humor everybody
and tell them that this uh I was the
sponsor of this original
legislation way back when when uh just
show you how old is John Burns was still
liquor chairman at the time and he
thought this was a great idea but um and
I was willing to go with only because uh
in in my bill at the time was to uh
reduce fees for direct the direct
shipper law which is my pride and joy
and and uh so and any rate uh I think at
this point we found out that enforcement
and this it was not it didn't pan out as
much as we would have liked it so
okay anybody like to make motion for
this
one I'll make a motion to op to
pass okay representative
Sullivan second by represent
spear moves out to
pass any discussion on the motion see
none all those in favor say
I two three four five six seven eight
seven eight that seven because we're
still yeah all this oppos more hands
seven zip okay moving right along okay
so this is
s
and okay what's
that we just voted the bill there's no
Amendment okay who who's whose name is
on the amendment oh representative Barry
has an amendment to
that2 uh oh what was in
Amendment if I recall the amendment was
just to uh change the
size okay all right um having voted on
the prevailing side I um asked to
reconsider um our action on 1321 all
those in favor please say I I okay so uh
it's just oh it changed from more than
seven gallons to 64 flu
ounces you guys care about
that 64 fluid
ounces seven g seven
gallons
okay what's
that
SC oh yeah right
okay right there you go of course that's
what you use cake but actually I thought
would people use those cakes for is to
distill
okay um all right so uh move to
reconsideration we voted in favor of
that so I'll now represent Sullivan
moves ought to pass on the amendment
number3
okay all those in favor of the amendment
please say I I opposed so that was that
was pass s zip okay representative Solan
second by representative spe moves ought
to pass as amended any discussion on the
motion see none all those in favor
please say
I those opposed so move
unanimously
okay
okay okay next is sale of beer in
refillable
[Music]
containers Growler
bill I thought we I thought everybody
liked this I thought everybody liked the
growers
okay one of my made no sense oh did we
didn't do it to you no okay you were
just oh
this you're killing
me we don't do that we are not
vindictive we don't do that okay
uh I don't this is whose pile is this
this this is what this is
okay right so um I would say that uh
over the years uh this issue had we've
had pass in the house um and and died in
the Senate um and then some years we
actually died in this committee and the
and the reason being was at one point in
time Growers was a really major thing
and it's and right now Growlers are um
they're not it's just not popular
anymore and so the issue just so
everybody remembers and I'm sorry I
wasn't was n here for this bill when we
did it that day the issue was that that
a when someone shows in with somebody
else's
Growler and says and and I want you to
feel feel it that well what happens if
that person doesn't do take good care
with that growler you know turns into to
be a bad beer or does something wrong to
it and someone else drinks it and say oh
my God that stuff is poison how you know
you know and starts you know posting on
Facebook that that you know the
bad beer when when it was simply could
have been somebody else's beer or could
you know whatever issues so generally um
Brewers have been opposed to it is any
Brewer here have any we don't even have
any c of Brewers okay so they didn't
even show up on this okay so like you
say in the old days they would all show
up and and overwhelmingly tell us not to
pass it right so um but at this point
it's they're less and less important in
terms of what now it's everybody it's
more about going in and tasting and
drinking and inside the facility which
is brings up a whole another set of
problems that we have with beverage
manufacturers but uh otherwise you know
it's people want the product they want
it in a can so okay so uh is there any
Amendment for this one no
okay all right
yes not being an expert on Growlers or
anything at least I know what they are
in in my town I see them being sold the
container is being sold all over the
place you're saying that it's not common
anymore I'm saying is yeah the idea of
of people going in and getting a growler
filled is is less and less happening
it's not if you were to ask a beverage
manufacturer which of course we don't
have any in the room um but you know the
only person the only one close to is
scotshire and he doesn't want Growlers
because they they distribute and they
don't distribute Growers so but um in
Growlers are just it's it's it was a
phenomenon at one point in time was
really cool it was you know that was
when it came when we first started out
with custom beverage manufacturers it
was very you know was absolutely Growers
was a part of their business um and but
now less and less so so I mean the fact
that they're willing to you know the
scheme of things that they're they're
they're obviously don't care
anymore
so but okay the motion
uh who's going to make the motion who
wants to carry this forward you want to
do this
John L to
pass
okay
okay okay representative pus second
representative hunt moves a to
pass any discussion on the motion of a
to pass for
Growlers this will allow this will be
allowed to refill a growler that's not
yours and that's up today and it's
enabling they can still say no
exactly they can say no we we don't we
don't trust
you somebody else's bot
though but the the crazy thing is you
would say is well you want somebody
walks in a Growler and you go well you
sure you how do we know how clean it is
so firsthand I saw how they clean a
growler they pour some poisonous stuff
in it it probably has
p and they shake it all about and they
rinse it out and it's
clean so might be one of the reasons why
people don't drink Growlers
anymore reusable Growlers
okay uh next one is
1702 oh I'm sorry okay all those in
favor of to pass to pass on 1334 four
please say I I those opposed so moved
seven is zip okay
1702 okay
1702 uh relative to the oversight of
Liquor Commission funding and repealing
the Liquor Commission fund
representative pusc wants to move
inexpedient to legislate yes I
do is a there an amendment Mr chairman
was going around for the bill if anybody
would to consider OTP on this bill but
okay which took care it's right on your
desk right beside you there I just
passed it around representative Maguire
and I introduced it oh
okay so you want to present your
Amendment yeah you want to present your
Amendment then certainly uh what this
does is a very simple thing it just
moves the uh the the alcohol treatment
fund from the liquor fund to the general
fund uh the most everybody that showed
up to testify against this bill spoke
about the liquor fund the treatment fund
what this does is it just keeps the fund
because if we were to take it out it
would basically do away with the fund
this just keeps it but moves it to the
general fund if we're going to move the
revenues to the general fund this moves
the uh the liquor treatment fund it
keeps the treatment fund at the 5%
funding and just moves it to the general
fund okay but this is only section one
of the bill so you're you're keeping the
rest of the bill the rest of the bill
would be kept yep just amend you really
want to move everything yeah into that's
the
intent so just so you know that whole
discussion about moving it from the
liquor fund to the general fund the the
the big thing I heard when that was
going on from the people who spoke on it
and I got one year okay was that and now
you're making the funding totally part
of the general budget yeah and so
whereas under our current system it's
locked into to a fixed percentage of
from what the Liquor Commission is
putting in there and you're now making
it vulnerable to
be lowered or raised but the thing is it
by the whim of the legislature yeah
there but there's no guarantee that they
get the 5% anyways because they've
suspended funding most of the years so
we haven't gotten the 5
per. so this is does no difference to
what's been going on now it just he
suspending of the funding no there's
many years they did not get the 5% oh
that well that's back when we were
having R even recently so how far is
recent so how long has it been since
that that's been
funded okay so um from someone from the
finance committee you guys when you cut
the funding and you just did it
notwithstanding the statute now I'm
looking at you mark yes yes I'm looking
at you now yes I'm looking at you now as
someone who said on the finance Comm you
come up to the mic when you sat on the
finance committee how how uh in terms of
the statutory requirement that it was
supposed to go to the general the liquor
fund but you you uh the wisdom of the
finance committee over the last couple
years you actually
didn't have that funding go through the
liquor fund or you you said
notwithstanding this I assume you must
have done this in house bill to you
would made the cuts and move the no Mr
chair that's not where the problem is
okay the problem is not with the the
fiscal committee it is not with the
finance committee the problem is with
the Liquor Commission as you will see
from the material that was given to
everyone The Liquor Commission has not
honored a series of its
obligations that the
legislature asked the Liquor Commission
to do when the liquor okay we're not
we're not testifying so you're you're at
this point you don't want to answer my
question I gu I will answer it I can
tell you my question is how could they
not if it says liquor fund how could it
be that we had in past years not gone to
the full Prof 5% who made that decision
The Liquor Commission that's my point
The Liquor Commission made that point
when made that decision when the Liquor
Commission became uh uh free of the fund
well it when it became free uh of being
a regular state agency so they could go
out and make millions for us they took
on full responsibility in fiscal year 16
even you know they they paid
1.7% 17 1.7% 18 3.4 I can go through all
the the numbers but you have just want
to know the Dynamics of how this all
happened the Liquor Commission refused
to honor their obligation just as the
Liquor Commission is obliged under the
law to every day put into I have an
amendment for that bill I have Amendment
for that statute and I have an amendment
that will change that to 30 days which
is what the current pattern in practice
is now so I'm just so yes so you are I
so you are your Amendment then would
take a step to have the Liquor
Commission come into compliance with
state law by changing the law correct
not by requiring The Liquor Commission
my understanding is that even that
everyone understood that one daily made
no sense whatsoever because it varies
from day to day
and there could be running funds and end
months going in that it had always been
p as a matter of fact when the statue
was first created they were paying on a
quarterly
basis they violated the statue right
from the get-go then then then they made
it to monthly when the current fiscal
off CFO was in there uh he made it
monthly and it has been monthly for
several years and yes I will change the
statute because daily makes absolutely
no sense whatsoever um did he or did The
Liquor Commission remember to tell
either the controller or the treasurer
of the State of New Hampshire what they
were going to do if you're going to make
this about a litness test on the
commissioner if the chairman if that's
what you want to turn this bill into
that's not fair you know that is not
fair Mr chairman you know you're not
going did he tell her or tell him
whoever was yes be you said that they
never did it they were required by law
the treasurer expected it when you look
at the management letters that have come
when you look at the communication from
the treasurer and from the controller
they were not in compliance if they're
going to be in compliance I think that's
fabulous I think that's great let's all
do let let them be in compliance good
but don't for a moment M Mr chair think
that you're going to get me to say oh my
my I'm not going to you know say what
what has been verified by those people
the state legislature has asked to be in
charge great okay representative
burrow yeah I just wanted to respond to
one thing that you said Mr chair was
that to make it monthly that's not going
to change the fact that they've not been
putting in the 5% no that's just a side
she she that was a side issue she okay
but but what I want to know is what do
we do to ensure that I mean if it is
going to stay the way it is now how do
we we how do we ensure compliance why is
it not being complied what do we need to
do to make ensure that happens so for
someone can uh can you tell us how it
could who who was in charge when it got
cut in the first place or who who who
who in the finance committee thought it
was okay to take to have less money come
in you're saying that the The Liquor
Commission didn't do it and you didn't
tell them that not what I said this is
the whole point I was I was on the
finance committee correct when the
decision was made to free The Liquor
Commission from the restraints of State
regulation right and they became you
know independent and off on their own
they then made a series of
decisions with which were in violation
of the current law and all that the the
prime sponsor is not in the state
otherwise he would be here all he's
asking and all all he's asked all along
is that the Liquor Commission comply
with the law that's all that I agree so
what so assuming that they're right now
they are now in compliance with funding
the liquor fund is that correct at the
moment yes you might want to find out
when they made that decision at this
point the only other issue we know that
is not being complied by the
commission is this one day versus 30
days and the commission is saying is 30
days makes perfect good sense everyone
thinks that 30 days is the right number
I maybe you think it really should be
daily rather than 30 days or are you uh
saying that if we amend that that
statute and bring it to 30 days that
would be a good thing to bring them in
compliance I don't know whether that
would be a good thing or a bad thing to
me it sounds like what you're doing is
saying if there's been a bad procedure
rather than change to a good procedure
will just make it legal to be bad but it
is not the only problem in this bill Mr
chair okay um and and there's
documentation there's another thing that
they're in violation of other than the
um in the LBA management
letter in 2020 said there is no formal
risk assessment process which everyone
in this room knows is essential the
commission responded that they are
actively in the process of creating a
formal internal audit two years later
the LBA said exactly the same thing and
the Liquor Commission responded with
exactly the same language they will it
it is complex they will they will figure
out what to do they are free of the
normal constraints and they are acting
in a way that shows they do not honor
the requirements of the law and they've
done it in situation after situation
great thank you very
much you don't really mean thank you Mr
chair I am always we've known each other
way too long I know thank you very much
representative
spear I I've listened to both sides of
this thing now quite a bit but
there are laws that they have to follow
and so there's procedures that we can do
to make sure that they follow those laws
we can do things about that by beating
him on the head or whatever it is that
we can do but last week I saw the
finance committee do something that was
so egregious that I would never give
them anything and as a result of that I
would never move this fund into the
finance committee because you don't
deserve
it
okay if you're talking about if you're
talking about the bill um that the
chairman just
waved oh absolutely and I would suggest
to you that you go back to
representative burrow and her suggestion
about to think about who's going to be
in the chairs in the
future thank you very much you want me
to leave now yes please oh you have a
question for her okay representative
Gibbs was next um well I actually um
have a comment so if representative
buroughs uh has a question maybe she
should go first and then I'll make my
comment okay thank you for taking my
question so okay so I have the same
concern UDA this hasn't been happening
and then this year they put the 5% in it
hasn't been by law they're required to
do it but it hasn't happened so what do
we do to make it happen I know you I I
think a lot of us are concerned about
moving it to the general fund because it
might not go where we want it to go so
do you see any solution other than to
send it to the general fund to get them
to do what's required by
law um I see solution but um because I
have I have looked with great respect
for many years on the chair of the
Commerce Committee if I suggest my my
solution I'm afraid that he will lose
any feeling of love and affection he has
for me and that is to say they have not
honored their obligation as an
Enterprise agency they haven't and I
mean and I and I say it in situation
after situation they look at how much
money they have borrowed borrowed what
they're paying in interest saying that
you know because they're expanding but
they're not bringing in any more Revenue
they're not bringing in more Revenue so
shouldn't they be limited a little
little bit in all their new spending
until they're able to bring in more
Revenue I don't know why they're not
bringing in new Revenue whatever the
reason is that's their problem they
chose to do to do that but when you look
at how much that Revenue they brought in
and you compare that with how much they
are borrowing and having to pay interest
on and they're free to do that because
they are an Enterprise operation they're
not a regular state agency I find that
very troubling so it is how the Liquor
Commission has been managed and there
might be perfectly legitimate reasons
let's find out what the legitimate
reasons are there might be things that
we should be doing in the legislature to
make it easier for the Liquor Commission
to be able to generate more Revenue but
right now we are they are the money
that's coming in to the Liquor
Commission
is not going to pay education it's not
going to pay um for to address drug
abuse it's paying to pay off it's going
to pay off the money that they've
borrowed and it's not good management
and the one thing I do know about the
chair of the Commerce Committee among
many others is that good management
matters to him and I think you ought to
take a look at that uh and figure out
where you want to go what what the prime
sponsor wanted to do in this bill and is
to say let's find a way to make sure
that the money goes to the
alcohol whatever that full name is you
know there's so many words in it I don't
remember at all um but the money should
go to it and it wasn't until there was a
Kur fluffle about this that suddenly
they put the right amount of money in
because somebody body was watching now
somebody ought to watch about how much
money they're borrowing as compared with
how much money they're taking in and
it's documented the control documents
the treasurer these are independent
people the legislative budget analyst
documents it it's not made up Mr chair
it's it's there it's true I noticed that
no one from The Liquor Commission
testified when this bill was presented
and and I don't blame them I wouldn't
have wanted to testify either because
those numbers they couldn't have argued
with okay okay all right representative
Gibbs
is thank you um
uh I have the greatest um respect for
the knowledge and experience of the past
speaker uh but I do think that it is
riskier to put this fund money into the
general fund uh than to have it
something that the Liquor Commission is
is required to put in I know that this
is the first year that they've put in
the full 5% in some years but it's my
understanding that each year the fund
did get something and knowing what can
happen in budget
negotiations uh I'm afraid that if this
were put into the general fund uh that
would be much riskier than having it uh
under the control of the Liquor
Commission because if it were in the
general fund and subject to full budget
negotiations the fund might get
nothing okay uh anybody else from the
committee so I would like to make a
motion of inexpedient to legislate
actually no have to do the I want to do
have to do the amendment first did we
actually move the amendment I think we
were just discussing it actually I think
let's do we'll do um in room study so
that we can have an explanation on the
funding and how the uh finance
department can Overlook the fact that
this money wasn't fully funded and how
and what's happening to the interest we
will we want to know what's happening to
the interest does that seem okay uh
representative grassy you okay with the
interim study okay a question so it was
brought up by uh representative uh Smith
that she she doesn't feel and and maybe
rightfully so cuz I don't I don't I have
never read the books is there some
formal way we can get an audit to or
something to figure out is there really
something that's yes as a matter of fact
that well there is the audit by the
budget the budget uh office of what it
what's the correct title office of the
legislative budget ass of budget which
is their office is right down after my
my Escape steps you know from the
state so anyways we will get their
reports and and the committee will
review it and get and get to the bottom
of these questions okay so I will make
the motion Mr chair yes uh are we
talking about the amendment right now no
the amendment is at this moment we never
move the amendment we never move the
amendment we were I only asked him is to
explain it and and at this point uh he
is okay for interim study okay I have
already moved itl 11
1702 it's in
study
um uh I didn't hear I did I I I didn't
hear is it okay if I do do you you
really want to do the motion if you want
to do it that's fine okay you want to
make the interim study motion
um okay okay representative
pusc moves inter room say then then may
say yes thank
you
okay is there any discussion on the
motion of interim
study all set all those in favor say I
all one two three four five six seven
eight
okay okay next up
18 always a pleasure to see
you right so now we have we have
four post oh oh she did vote okay so she
isn't she's here
now
that's okay what's next here this
is
um
10:18
that okay right
was all
right right do we have the
amendment good so which which amendment
are we working on now
the okay
okay all
right here's a synopsis okay
uh oh yeah so that I had this this is
what I had in my hand the problem was
the Z at the bottom
there and that no level of
exposure so I'm I'm looking at
0110 and down on line
30 it said that no Z is in sleeping
no level of exposure of secondhand smoke
is safe that was supposed to be level
that is that
correct okay so what we want to do today
because like you say we're whether we
get through all these bills you know
there's going to be a point where we
might just say we've had enough of this
um that um that this one we'll take up
but is there any other questions with
this amendment of as 10:18 is written is
everybody okay I know a lot of you are
in this room for
this
okay and that
is
okay on page two oh as introduced
okay thanks okay as introduced T
okay
what what was
it yeah licensed is it says licensed is
still
here oh it needs to say it
again okay so you guys will have that
amendment made up for me with and and
then email me and then I'll get it to
legislative services and so the next
time we take up this liquor bill we'll
have this
corrected
okay
1076 okay what is this this one anybody
have a copy of it it's this one
de
okay 10 oh no that's 1018 we
doing you're doing 1076 yeah
um doesn't mean I know what's in
it uh
okay
a clean up yes this is
housekeeping you
beverage no the on
premise the manufactur
facility
manufactur
okay so with this so this bill needs to
be
amended okay the for the purpose of this
pair the UN premise licensing may be the
on premise of the manufacturer facility
or on the premises of the wine
manufacturer retail
outlet or oh this is your notes or
beverage manufacturer retailer assume
that that must come from the discussion
wasn't right must
change okay the
holder an un premise license see it's a
discretion
of
so the question is as adding beverage
manufacturer this
is Danielle you this might be a Bure
adding beverage manufacturer retail
outlet what what is a beverage
manufacturer retail outlet we didn't
even have a license like that I don't
know was
okay right right you can only have one
license yeah okay that's the only I got
okay what would why don't you come up
here and tell me what problem I was
trying to
solve thank you chairman and committee
members uh I if I can decipher your
notes here you're proba you are
referring to the beverage manufacturer
retail out way so what the the bill that
is proposed is saying each wine
manufacturer is entitled to it one on
premises license at their their
manufacturing facility this bill would
they also entitled to one wine
manufacturer retail
outlet so this bill would allow them to
have their on premises
license either at their manufacturing
facility or the retail
outlet so I believe um represent this is
the Madam label
this label originally wanted that
offsite location the the wine
manufacturer retail manufacturer wanted
the offsite location that so we're now
we're saying is that that that
manufacturing can occur at either one
it's not locked into the on premises
license that they're entitled to can be
on the premises of the manufacturing
facility or the beverage manufacturer
retail outlet yeah right okay because
there there has been circumstances where
the manufacturing facilities are not
zoned properly for a restaurant they're
not they can't they don't have the means
to be able to have that so if they were
to have the retail outlet which is an
add-on to the license they would be able
to have their on premises license there
their restaurant license there and this
similarly this language is is found in
the beverage manufacturer license that's
that's what where representative svin is
referencing the beverage manufacturer we
already G we already gave it to them but
we just now we're going back to the
original uh entity which was
wine okay anybody have a problem with
this bill no just to clarify you're
gonna have you now they can have a
retail store and um that sells I mean
that oh the retail outlet will be able
to serve liquor and just like wine wine
wine not liquor that would be a liquor
store so yeah yeah right right so we
can't do the liquor store but the wine
is uh they're able to add on an
additional license to have a retail
outlet where they sell their wine only
their wine right so that could be a
separate location so so now now they can
have both right onsite and in a retail
they're already able to have onsite
right both but they're right now they're
only allowed to have their restaurant
license that they're entitled to under
the statute on their manufacturing
facility this would allow them to choose
whether they want that one license on
the manufacturing facility or the retail
outlet which could be it two separate
locations but it doesn't unless we make
that change that I wrote my notes on
right correct okay for the wine we
haven't not address the beverage
manufacturer we haven't addressed them
yet this all started out with leel
wanted had that big facility on in in
Amherst there and then she wanted to
have a in one of the outlets I think it
was the marac outlet she wanted to put a
put a a location inside there okay and
we allowed her and that and that that
was a whole Hua all right because now
we're having separate location and that
she was going to have be allowed to sell
wine in that location it had to be only
her wine originally the commission's
position is no they need to make wine
inside that facility and everybody says
no we don't think that's probably a
really good idea to them to have a
little wine making business inside the a
mall you know and so that that the
conclusion was we'll give them the right
to have that other location now we're
saying is that location can actually be
an off- premise license on premise licy
which means a restaurant it could be a
restaurant on premise
lcy so I have a a a question is this
just for one individual that came to you
no be all wine there's we got other wine
people here right no this is this is a a
request that's been made several times I
guess we don't have any wine people
here I see is so the question is are we
changing my Mr chair Bing people doing
here my question is is my note does that
need to be added on to it I something it
does so the question is is that should
we also
add for beverage manufacturers the same
privilege um and is what you're posing
the question and sort of like uh let's
let let's nip this in the bud before one
of them comes and ask us to do that so
that would require just a little bit of
an amendment that would requireed
amendment that correct but you're
changing 17812 not 1788 in that instance
in that case so but 178 so therefore
right now do we
allow an individual right now beverage
manufacturers don't have that privilege
they do not have this privilege that it
is before the committee now yeah right
and if we're going to give it to okay so
that's what we want an amendment for to
add beverage manufacturer to get the
same privilege as this
exactly
okay got it nice whose coffee was this
whose coffee was
this yeah it post
y okay
good sorry I didn't come prepar for
class
today
okay all
right okay next
is actually now that I have a feeling
for what who's left in the room why
don't we why don't we just tackle these
two we got two issues yours is a little
bit easier with the back row is going to
be it's going to take some time okay so
uh which one which one is you got your
bill you're here
for which
one okay so we'll take up
15 no not
1591 oh it's the last one
okay all
right okay so do we have an amendment
for this
one
anybody speak now for more hold piece we
have an amendment on this one are we all
set with this
one no this is the one this is the one
we got to take out paragraph right yeah
we we need an amendment on this one
right so is this is this the one chist
that I had
the
1591 so I don't we have what happened to
the amendment to
I could have sworn I had we this
amendment has been done right you I sent
you a guys a copy of that Amendment
right we somebody must have this
amendment
right did you get a copy of the
amendment I don't have
one no this wouldn't have been handled
out of the bill this would have come
later um was this the amendment for uh
not penalizing the uh the kids this uh
Amendment if I have it correctly we're
removing a paragraph in which paragraph
okay it's it's the last paragraph
right section six of the
bill and it wasn't there one other word
change somewhere else in there too that
was
just I know
I
um okay this bill is
what
would I have Aiden to do this
amendment all
right I could have sworn the amendment
was done
no no you wouldn't have it in your I
it's the problem is we don't have the
file right no we don't have the file I
can go get it or she can go
right chis did you just go check the
file and see if it's stuck in
there
okay just take that is this 1591 is that
what were
yeah this yeah this is your it's just
not seeing all my
mail this a dumb idea
the usually there's
amendments I ask because these bills all
these bills they ask me to put in so I
would have them give me the change and
then I would send it to ol they would
have it done and then normally I then
send it to them to make sure it's right
but you hav't I don't I
don't it's probably it all too many too
many
bills I I could have swor I did
but okay
so yeah nothing
nothing no no okay we'll we'll just say
I'm GNA make my needs
Amendment
okay so before we we before we end the
discussion on this
1591 uh
having if you have the bill in the front
have removing that last paragraph Does
anybody have a problem with 1591
everybody else is going to be okay with
1591 what was is that with or without
change what which
Bill where's the gief Danielle which one
did I add delta8 and Delta 9 I thought I
was going to add it to this
one right
Del right so it was supposed to in this
bill
right and whatever happened to
it all right I'll be better prepared
next time okay so just so we know we're
going to remove this paragraph section
six and add a new section six because
that's the last one I think or maybe we
were going to add the Banning of the
main continue the ban oh no we were
going to add
what what was the amendment going to be
so the amendment was we originally
talked about the amendment will make
Delta 8 Delta 9 Delta 10 the authorized
products 21 plus right right they will
also require lenses to comply with the
statute that puts the parameters on um
the the range of Delta we could not put
it under a license that you needed a
license to sell it because it's in the
definition of hemp and I don't think
that was something we all had the energy
to tackle right now was regulating hemp
so the he just left the room the hemp
the hemp gr so the amendment makes it 21
plus there's penalties for selling under
to someone under the age of 21 uh
possession and then it requires licenses
for us to comply with the Delta
statutes okay
does anybody have a problem with
that you're yeah because you get to sell
it
now I'm sure you'll be okay I was more
looking at the two people behind
you
right oh they have a
senate they have bill they already have
a bill to extend the
sunset oh they were going to extend the
sunset we can so what would you rather
do extend the sunset or would you rather
have
us that's fine okay fine we'll wait for
that then okay all right so never mind
about the Delta 8 Delta 9 and Delta 10
now we have a Delta 10 all Del all
Deltas all deltas Delta Dent right okay
all right but but just section six is
what we're going to take out okay so
sorry that you guys had to wait here to
get to that place but at least now you
don't have to wait for that one okay so
are we gonna so we have one more I want
to take up and then and then we I think
we've had enough of this okay the one we
want to take up
is uh 1380 is that correct 1 1380 right
1380 uh we gonna take up um oops yards
15 um we we could talk about his but I
want to do 1380 because I don't know how
long this conversation is going to last
okay so um what we'll do is um I guess I
can paint the picture here what we have
here was a
situation um uh that
um for better for worse
the solution to a problem was that in
our statutes uh we have this um three
tier requirement it doesn't they don't
call three tier but it's basically a
separation of involvement of one
business versus the other business of
the three different tiers and remind
everybody the three tiers is
manufacturing
Distributing and then and then retailing
or which can be um on or off premise
licy the issue uh was that we had that
you couldn't if you own one you can't
own another you're that that everybody's
kind of separated into their to their
Silo
um better for worse and I and I the best
offense I can say this all happened
before me I know you guys think I've
been here all all forever but that the
legislature in its wisdom decided to um
create a concept called a brew
Hub and a brew Hub is a total violation
of the three- tier system because it's a
manufacturer that distributes to itself
deliver takes it from one side of the
room to the other side of the room and
then sells it on as an on premise
licy um the other things that they was
in the legislature is they required it
to it had a cap 2500 barrels it had um
it had to get a full liquor
license so it wasn't just a a beverage
manufacturer it was it was a it had so
it end up having distilled
drinks so it wasn't a beer and wine
lensey but it um I think those are the
the most Salient items what occurred was
that we have some somebody who owns does
he already own a brew do he already own
a brew pub Brew Pub does he already own
a brew
pub does not own a brew pub now so what
happened was is that he um he has
restaurants but he would like to own a
brew pub and he would like to be able to
have uh the beer that he's brewing in
this beer pu to be sold in his other
restaurants which would be on the face
of it that is a violation of our our the
the title it's it's not three CH what do
we call this title it's uh no I know
title No the
uh prohibited interests that's the key
word prohibited interests okay so
um in this issue and yes my name is on
this bill um what became uh clear
was issue was that that when we created
the Nano legislation which yes I was in
the room when that happened the Nano
legislation which we thought we were
just going to be little small little
started reppers and that they would grow
up and be big boys and be real beverage
manufacturers it was always the theory
of Nanos but it didn't turn out that way
and it turns out that there are some
people who are very happy being Nanos
and and we have like 30 40 of them and
lot we have a lot of Nanos
um and and they definitely have a lesser
license it's a cheaper
license um and they have the capability
of one of the first legislation I did
which is they can self-distribute they
you know they can be they didn't need
Distributors they could actually a nano
can distributor and we have a one Nano
guy actually delivers to your house so
we had a
Manchester so in this prohibitive
interest concept the the fact was that
when we wrote the statute we of Nanos we
didn't go over to the prohibited
interest and add Nano to the list at the
time we didn't do that because we didn't
never crossed our mind that that would
get caught up in a
problem the upshot was when this
gentleman who wants to have a um wants
to have he already owns these
restaurants he wants to create a brew
pub and and have that beer distributed
uh was told that he couldn't do it
because of the prohibited interest
statute and they said um oh by the way
you could be a nano and that way you can
get around it and so everybody said oh
that's a great idea let's let him just
be a nano well as you might be aware the
Senate right now has another piece of
legislation that they're sending over to
us that gets rid of Nanos repeals it and
instead instead we're going to have a
tiered system of Beverage mean
manufacturers what you can you're you're
tearing and so the um what you're going
to hear and I will
invite the the party who is in
opposition because because when when I
heard of this idea of the Brew Pub uh it
seemed simple enough to me to um just
simply you know let the Brew Pub um
except it which says 5,000 barrels and
that really should be 2500 if you're
looking at the actual bill but anyway so
the issue then was that um the beer
distributors are saying we're trampling
on this prohibited interest statute uh
that we're violating federal law and uh
who knows what nightmares we were
creating by doing this and that why
wouldn't we just do something that yes
I'm been around long enough to know this
trick and that is you pass the law and
then and then you wait 10 minutes when
you pass the bill you say it's effective
at a certain time and then you pass
another law that's effective 10 minutes
later okay so you would say July 1st mid
at midnight and then you would say July
1st at
1210 and that way U we could allow this
gentleman who wants to have this uh uh
Brew Pub uh to uh to be uh be a nano not
a brute Pub be a nano and then have uh
he can distribute it to all the
restaurants as a self-d distributor um
instead of having a brew pub license um
I when I first heard about where I
wasn't really aware of too much of the
detail of the Nano I I guess I did know
about the Nano problem but it didn't it
always felt for me personally that when
we do legislation we normally know that
everything we do here as mother mayi
that everything's illegal until we say
it's legal and so if you know where how
do I feel about a brw hub Distributing
to other restaurants that are owned by
that same facility and the classic
example I would always say is
well common man's got his own beer but
they don't make it they they license it
from a beverage manufacturer and puts
that label on it and then
I don't I don't know if it's distributed
or or self-distributed to Sonny those to
they probably take it in and fill a
truck and they take it over to the
common man's warehouse and Common Man
then distributes all the stuff but
that's legal because we pass a statue
that allowed for contract brew and as a
matter of fact we have a bill in this
year to tighten up or add the confusing
of uh of um terms of the C that kind of
Brewer that Brewer versus uh doesn't
matter so the issue now at at hand
is what is a brw pub is a brew pub a
restaurant that happens to make beer and
so therefore they want to distribute
that beer to all their locations or is
it a beverage
manufacturer and therefore it would be a
violation for them to sell beer to their
other locations representative Wells
thank you chairman uh I'm going to defer
to all of your great knowledge in this
how is this different from 1076 once
it's amended to include beverage
manufacturers isn't this basically the
same issue what 10 what's 1076 was wine
but we're going to add so um I'm getting
yeah so
1076 is is really about
uh it is true that they're talking about
an on- premise license okay and I would
say that that was actually one of the
Battlegrounds on whether why we allow
that legislation so what's different
right now in terms of this
conversation is uh they have more than
one restaurant they have several
restaurants they even have a bakery I
guess
y so whereas that bill was only one
location and believe you me that was a
battle royale just to get to that one
location so and and along the similar
items here so if I I look at the three
people did I articulate the the
discussion correctly okay so what we
have here
just some of you might know Mike Summers
uh well because he's been here for many
times and he represents the restaurants
and uh and Association and this is
obviously one of his his clients who
would like to uh pass this bill to allow
his The Brew Pub for formula and in the
back of the room and we have one person
you have not maybe seen before is a a
real live beer distributor who's come to
us and of course Scot sh who you have
seen in past so I will start with them
and have them come up and make the
argument to why you because you guys
never actually spoke against this bill
in the hearing right you didn't just
sign okay great so now is now is your
opportunity with half the committee here
to make the case for why we should do 12
midnight and and
1201 for those I haven't met my name is
Joe bellavance I'm one of the owners of
bellavance Beverage uh we are a
distributor in more the southern portion
of the
state and for the record I'm Scott Shire
the executive director of the beer
distributors Association thank you for
your time and uh this important matter
I'm going to try to keep this as short
and sweet as possible because I know
that it's been a long day for everybody
especially those who thought we started
at 10 um but oh well so um here's the
essence of it we and the State Liquor
Commission and they can correct me if
I'm wrong classify a brew pub as a
manufactur so the manufacturer exists in
the middle one of the tiers right the F
this is the first tier actually
manufacturer sometimes referred to as a
supplier or a brewer or a wine maker or
a distiller so they exist within that
category the middle tier is distributors
or
wholesalers and the other tier is the
retailers which can be a restaurant they
could also be a hotel and they could
also be a grocery store so that
separation exists to this day and
representative hunt
illustration of the Brew Pub and the
trampling of the three- tier system is
not entirely inaccurate but I will say
that that Brew Pub does hold a
manufacturer's license they have retail
Privileges and distribution privileges
that go with that manufacturer's license
so that's the real difference they're
within one
category versus within two now in the
case of Mr summers's member he has
retail licenses which are restaurants so
they exist in the retail tier and now he
wants to open up a brew pub which is a
manufacturer and exists in the
manufacturer tier this would be the
first time we would allow this cross
tier ownership since before
prohibition and this is a very important
distinction and it's a lot more serious
then some might think it's not just for
one
restaurant but it's for the all the
particip ipants in the industry that
play by the same set of rules with
regulation uh representative hunt also
indicated correctly that the federal
government does have a Prohibition
against tide house or cros tier
ownership it's in chapter 27 of the
federal alcohol act and that's been
existence again since the repeal of
prohibition I'm not going to get into
too much more detail but I will tell you
that sometimes
it's more important to focus on the
research and the facts and the data um
I'm not saying that uh you know we don't
have good insights into this but I'd
refer to a study that I'm going to hand
out to everybody and and I'll have to
email this to the committee too because
I don't have enough copies for everybody
today but um I'll pass that out and um
I'll let Joe say a couple of words and
I'd be happy to answer any
questions
and I would say that the the three- tier
system has existed for a long time um
some people knock it because of its age
however it has worked very well you have
over a hundred craft breweries in the
state right now um one of the concerns
about this bill is not so much the
individual location um Michael runs a
great business and if he wants to make
beer at one of his
locations hey that's probably not a big
deal but if you take the law as it's
proposed to be changed
and carry that out across multiple
locations the concern becomes what now
if he only wants to sell his beer at his
other seven locations and the 603s and
the heners and the small breweries of
the world um and ourselves the products
that we represent those are the ones we
do um now are excluded from being served
in those accounts and he only wants to
serve his own beers because cost
structures and other reasons um make
sense so maybe that's two or three
locations but let's look at the common
man that came up that's a perfect
example they do a contract beer right
now what if they open their own Brewery
and across all Common Man locations now
all those New Hampshire Brewers were
excluded and Common Man only wanted to
sell the beer that they produced there
so um it's not that farfetched if you
think very simply you probably all have
your favorite restaurants you can either
get a Coke or a Pepsi but usually not
both
Coker Pepsi pays for the exclusive
rights at those restaurants and
therefore you only have one choice or
the other choice three tier does not
allow that that's why you have over a
100 craft bries in the state why you
have diverse selection of beer uh at the
various restaurants uh that we have here
in the state and um that is our bigger
concern is that this just isn't isolated
to one location but that it could be
expanded and have Ripple effects um for
ourselves and for the craft Brewers in
the state across many of these
restaurants and just to add to that
quickly um we know the Michael Timothy
group very very well they're excellent
partners of ours and Joe's got a good
personal relationship with them this is
important to us if it wasn't important
we wouldn't be having this fight but
this is changing the entire regulatory
system and I do believe that there are
other ways to handle this
without breaking this long held
prohibition of of prohibited interest
that that exists in the state um
representative Hunt's idea um certainly
is one one way to do it I think that um
there's been conversations among
stakeholders with the Liquor Commission
about other ways to possibly handle this
um but we're firmly supportive of the
regulatory system that's provided safety
um access to Consumers good competition
for businesses and Equitable access for
businesses of all SI sizes in beverage
alcohol and I think representative hunt
mentioned it during his uh statements on
1633 if you don't have any control
things can really get out of order right
away like in
main so represent buo has a question I
just have a comment I don't think that
would be a good business model for you
know restaurants to be only selling one
beer it just wouldn't make sense to a
you know very successful restaurant tour
can you comment on that thanks to the
question I 100% agree with you it
wouldn't make sense but there have been
situations in the past where
manufacturers have had their own retail
outlets and um they control the price
and the supply of the products and
sometimes they drop it to knock people
out of out of business and then they can
raise the prices when they're done and I
think that while we haven't seen that as
much in the United States in the last 90
years you just have to look South of the
Border in Mexico or South America or
even in the UK to see the limits that
are put on the the regulatory
Marketplace by tide house and I I would
just add the uh I think the economics of
that production obviously would bypass
the middle tier so there is a greater
gross profit on those products that um
the location would manufacture so
there's an economic incentive there um
yes I agree consumer wise you might be
challenged to only offer those at least
the environment we're in
now so
Joe we known each other a long time and
what was the first bill that I brought
in that we had this little mono mono
discussion on it was probably
self-distribution self-distribution
right and once again I or no for the
first time I was well actually the drip
shiing law could be say I was somewhat
trampling on the three tier because I
was going across state lines with my
trampling but that statute was trampling
on the three
tier and the compromise that we had
was that there was a limit to how much
could get self-distributed
correct yeah so
again if we look at this legislation and
like I say it's it shouldn't be five
should be 2500 because that's what you
know we that's the the current
limitation of a brew
Hub okay are you saying that 2500 if
they're limited to
2500 I mean you've done the math how
much money would you really make if you
were involved in the Distributing of
2500 barrels and so all I'm saying is is
this is treated this okay if they're
going to treat him as a beverage
manufacturer and they are
self-distributing
okay and what the self-d distrib law
what did we say that it's a th000
barrels I'm trying to remember what for
brw pubs it's 2500 I know but what was
the what did what was the bill would you
and I compromise that 30 years ago what
was average manufacturers yeah 10,000
10,000 no was 15,000 total and I think
5,000 in state oh 5,000 okay five
so using your comparison that a brew
pub is a beverage
manufacturer I didn't a manufacturer the
manufacturer
tier okay so why shouldn't we be giving
them the right to
self-distribute it's it's not about that
it's only because he owns those other
facilities correct okay that's the only
difference here right and we're worried
about that he's going to turn into
anheiser Bush and be a tide house and
that's that's who we're talking about
the tigh house
legislation concept was worried about
anheiser Bush and Miller and you know
cores maybe no we're we're not worried
about that happening here in the state
what we're worried about is the
precedent that might be set that might
encourage others like Amazon who owns
Whole Foods already or somebody else
getting into the business and ultimately
cutting out small neighborhood Family
run businesses in the state but they can
only self only deliver 500 barrels I'm
pretty sure Amazon would think that
ain't worth the effort to buying a brew
pub and doing that self-distributing for
barrels that's what I'm saying is same
compromise Joe same compromise we had
before with it's put a cap and and and
and my memory was that you guys said to
me was was that you don't make any money
unless you were Distributing more than
that 10,000 or whatever that 5,000 that
number that we had agreed upon yeah I
don't think there was a numeric value we
placed on it but we did recognize that
there were certain small Brewers proof
of concept that needed to have an
incubator and be able to get the public
their be to determine whether there's
some commercial viability isn't 2500
small isn't that kind of a small you
would I would say that 80% of the
Brewers in the state are below 2500 so
it sounds like it's a small number but
it's actually pretty 38,000 cases of
beer 12 ounce 24
pack and again again not if I may not to
get up off track but just we're talking
about prohibited interest Clause here
not how much somebody can distribute
right you know you can get multiple Brew
Pub licenses if you want to have a
restaurant and a manufacturer and that
in fact is being done by people in the
state right now multiple Brew Pub
licenses that's a way to skin this
cat without changing the system and
without Crossing he would have to
manufacture in each one of those
restaurants Define manufacturer in
statute I I I don't want someone to have
a a keg in the corner
and I don't we didn't remember we didn't
like them doing that in the mall because
we didn't want them to have the you know
because you got to do some heating up
and we didn't think that was a good idea
to have
them bring in that high voltage wire and
who knows with liquids and so
um I urge you to think of some kind of
compromise that we can do here is that's
we have been working very Harding you
but that I I you know now I'm speaking
for myself and I can't say what my other
committee members is but to to play the
you know Nano game and for for 10
minutes and then change it and say okay
now they're grandfathered um that is
really tacky and and just the idea that
we we know for well and we're getting
rid of Nano so why would we why would we
want them to be a nano when we know
we're going to get rid of that statute
so yes if I may there's only one ly in
the state that we know of right now that
falls into this category and they're in
the process of applying for their Nano
Brewing license they they don't have it
yet they're in the process and after you
know let's just say that you know a
generation goes by 20 years or so and
they decide they're no longer in the
business once they're they're out
they're out they're out I mean you can't
get it back then that loophole that was
created back when the Nano was passed is
closed and quite frankly it should have
been closed years ago but it didn't get
closed so now we don't want to authorize
a loophole with a statute that changes
the regulatory system that's been we
don't want to do the Nano we don't want
to do the Nano that's the whole point we
want it to be a brew pup no but he's
applying it because that's what he was
told the only way he could do this is
that a nano is not prohibited a
prohibited interest because it was not
put into the statute I think what they I
think the solution is what you just said
that you didn't want I think that's a
perfect
okay so okay representative wals do you
have a question yes thank you I'm still
trying to catch up on all of this stuff
is the difference the main difference
between this bill and 1076 the number of
barrels is that because they seem
essentially the same as far as on Prem
in ter right so it is it is similar in
the sense that um a another one of our
quote unquote trampling on the three
tier that we allowed uh beverage
manufacturers and in this case wine
manufacturers right to own a restaurant
restaurant oh okay that's the on you
know the on premise license is
restaurant right okay now meanwhile you
know they say if you want to go back to
where so this is a restaurant that wants
a license he wants he wants to you know
and and he wants to also he has a bunch
of restaurants and he wants to be able
to brew his own beer and distribute to
all those locations much similar to
let's say what the Common Man does but
the difference being is he wants to brew
it
himself whereas the Common Man contracts
it out by a third- party company third
party manufacturer not being a a beer
Enthusiast but with wine I happen to
frequent leels and dairy often and I
know when I go to lael's I'm only going
to get leel wine so if I go to a brew
pub that brews their
own beer or ale that's kind of you know
like if you go to Guinness in Ireland
you're going to get
Guinness so that's because they really
they don't have a problem with tight
houses right well you I guess I don't I
don't see the problem I guess visual the
problem is is that in this case these
are all these different restaurants so
the fear is that if that rest all those
restaurants are dependent upon one
manufacturing
facility okay the fear was of Tide
houses that that aneis are Bush because
they can produce more beer than
than that God needs and and therefore
would then come into a bar and and and
basically and they always the fear was
strong arming them but that you know
saying that you're this is the only one
you were going to sell and then that
would force little guys out of the
business may I ask another but that's
not the same here because in your
example and Heiser Bush would own the
own that Brew pup we're talking about
the owner right now we don't allow Riser
Bush to own restaurants that's right
that's so it's not quite Apples to
Apples right right or beer to beer
that's the reason why this that other
bill that's why that bill is not the
same as this bill so yeah Scott you want
to respond to that yeah thanks for the
question representative Walsh I think
the difference here and this getss
really confusing is
that with respect to the wine
manufacturer retail outlet or the
beverage manufacturer retail outlet
those are a restaurant they are offsite
from the original location but they are
a privilege of the manufacturer's
license they are not a retail license so
they exist still within this
manufacturing tier they're not Crossing
into another tier and the fear here is
is just setting a precedent we have
never allowed cross tier ownership we
just like we don't allow people to pay
for space in the grocery store which is
why when you go to Hanford you will see
probably 100 different labels of beer
there and when you go into the potato
chip aisle you're going to see you know
40 ft of Fredo products and maybe a few
locals and that's about it and it's the
same thing people pay for that space
you're not allowed to do it it's the
same Principle as having somebody own
the retail store and the production
facility that makes the product that
they're
selling I'm pretty sure that if it's a
bakery everything they bake inside there
is their their stuff just the
[Laughter]
alcohol okay so obviously we're not
going to solve this today um we do have
a deadline uh come next month and so we
hope we can figure out some solution
here but I did want to make sure all the
committee members are are informed of
the discussion but I do want to allow
mik sure I was just going to say that if
there are questions that we can't answer
um I'm sure that the folks behind us
from The Liquor Commission can because
they're the experts on regulatory
matters
okay thank you very much thank you all
for the opportunity thank you nice to
see you Joe okay you get the last word
here
Mike thank you Mr chairman committee I
appreciate the opportunity to rebot a
little here um so a few comments
um where to begin so obviously uh there
was some discussion about this is about
one license e it's really not about one
license e as as uh the previous speakers
mentioned this it really is about an
indust industry change because and I
want to give paint a little bit of a
picture for you but you know I I find it
interesting that over the years since
the Nano browers came around and the
beverage manufacturers have been busily
trampling the three- tier system and
shipping away at restaurants
competitiveness in the in the market
space nobody objected to any of that
except for me I was the only guy that
objected
um but when we talk about a manufacturer
has a retail location that's a violation
of three- tier system if they have a
restaurant that is technically a
violation three- tier system because
they're operating as a manufacturer and
they're in the retail sector uh but
that's okay for the breweries and the
wineries but it's not okay for
restaurants to go the other way and this
has been going on for the better part of
15 years maybe longer but at least 15
years and so really all we're asking for
is the ability for a restaurant owner to
have a brew pub to essentially compete
in the same space
so for us and for our members and for my
board who really adopted our policy uh
supporting this um this is about being
able to compete uh competitively in the
same space and and you have to
understand the advantage of being a
manufacturer the manufacturer they are
getting their product to resell at
retail they're getting it at Cost versus
wholesale which is what common man is
getting through a contract Brewing
relationship versus buying it you know
or through a distributor so this just
gives a restaurants the competitive
ability to the ability to compete
competitively with all of the Brew PB
breweries that are out there now that
are selling in many cases without any
kind of food restrictions or
requirements and so that really has
become kind of the Crux of the issue for
a lot of our
guys I will also say that whilst I
certainly have one member who testified
at the original hearing on this bill I
have received numerous uh businesses
that have attempted to do this and I
think the commission could testified to
this as well businesses who had wanted
to do this in in the last few years so
this is not just about one LC e this is
about an industry that has been been
chipped away at by the Brey industry and
we're just trying to get into a
competitive set with these guys
um the other thing I will say is you
know it's not like every restaurant is
going to rush out and open a brew pub
the sheer cost of opening a brew pub is
is prohibitive uh Ian Buckley when he
testified mentioned that he was into the
in for the tune of $12 million this is
not Trump change right this is a
significant commitment and so I don't
suspect there's going to be a whole ton
of restaurants that are going to do this
assuming that you allow them right to do
so this is going to be very limited
group of people and they are already
restricted by their distribution amounts
of 2500 barrels and I will also say that
you know in conversations with a number
of restaurants that have uh Brew Pub
licenses now you know they they they
consume at their original location
almost a th000 barrels a year in beer
just for that location so really when
you talk about seven restaurants he's
probably not going to be able to make
enough beer to distribute to all of his
restaurants anyway it's going to be kind
of like a house offering but he's going
to have a whole bunch of other
selections available that he's going to
have to buy from other Distributors Etc
so this is this is not going to be a
fundamental shift in the industry it's
going to be a teeny tiny piece of what's
going to happen uh in the industry as a
whole um I think that's it I won't beat
the dead horse I apologize but thank you
for the opportunity to get apologize for
not beating a dead
buo yeah you were talking about um other
um restaurants that you know were
thinking of doing what Buckley is you
know was doing but have any of them
spent millions of dollars to get ready
to do what he thought he could do no
because in in the in the SC scenario
we're talking about those people had
looked to buy a an existing Brew pup
they went to the commission commission
told them you can't buy it because it
crosses the tier so that killed
essential an entrepreneurial effort to
re to rescue a business that I I think a
couple of them went out of business
right so that's jobs lost meals and
rentals tax revenues lost etc etc in
this particular instance this is a brand
new build so he went to the Liquor
Commission and he was told well you
can't get licensed as a brewbot but we
have this really creative workaround
which as a state I don't like the idea
of workarounds right I think we should
allow it the right or not allow the
right and so but with the with the
nanoor license he could get a workaround
so he would get license in Arab Brewery
he would also have under the same roof a
restaurant license the only restriction
would be he would have to have a wall
dividing the two licenses and he'd have
to drive the beer out through the
parking lot and deliver it to the
restaurant which just seems like a weird
scenario to me and I think for most
people one other thing I will say is
when you look at a brew pop license I
know there's a lot of talk about it
being a manufacturer's license but it is
no more a manufacturer's license than it
is a restaurant license because it is a
full-blown restaurant it has uh beer
wine spirits it has food requirements it
meets every other standard that they
have to meet in order to be a full
restaurant so it is no more a
manufacturer than a restaurant than it
is a restaurant versus a manufacturer so
it's this weird hybrid that the state of
New Hampshire has created and so we just
see this as kind of an incremental way
for us to continue to remain
competitive representative
spear from your experience a lot of our
our three tier uh implementation if you
will came about as a result of getting
rid of
prohibition isn't it essentially right
it was created the end of
yeah it really does seem like it's time
to modernize a little
bit and start being a little bit more
flexible I don't know just a
thought um so just so you know the
Liquor Commission which is our still is
still considered a three-tier
model and wait till you hear how that
Byzantine model works
out okay thank you very much Mike thank
okay all right enough of that one um the
time is 3:30 we can you want to talk
about your bills I I I I much as I would
love to go over to Delta Dental which is
at
4 um and because whenever I show up um
he he always has to announce that that
this committee crafted the legislation
that created the delta dendel corporate
structure and uh so he he always likes
to do a oh so he to be so but I I I my
wife wants me to come home so I am not
going to go but I want to make sure you
guys all go right so then you can all
and and
and it's over Del Dental Delta Dental oh
they they party it's a event
for oh yeah it's it's you it's like
you're going you go to Constitution
Avenue like you're about to get on the 4
93 or3 whatever that is going over but
you get down and get off
and Google it Google it Google it okay
so that gives
you 20 minutes to discuss it or do you
want to
wait yeah or you want to
wait which one of we start because there
a bunch of them on here what did we
cover when I was gone because I had to
go speak to a bill say it again what did
I miss because I had to speak to a bill
uh we were just you wanted to speak on
you doesn't did we didn't take up your
bills no no yeah what bills do we take
up I'm just trying to keep track I I
showed you uh 15 we talked about 1591
And1 108 and then 1018
1380 and 1380 was the one we were just
discussing Al so we didn't really get
too much through so I I think we really
don't have much time unless you really
want to tackle one of them all
right kick him
off um I mean there are three bills I
care about two of them are mine and
one's not mine so it doesn't matter to
me we can go into some of them or not
uh right who what what are you here for
I'm
sorry
1358 the contract bill so I I must I
have that Amendment done right that's
the amendment I do
have okay let's do this one let's just
get this one all right thank you
the
yeah and he's here so let's do it so he
doesn't have to come back again even
though I'm sure you just thought have
how much was fun enjoying on this
conversation yeah that's
fine yeah
okay okay as we were talking about
contract Brewers now we're going to talk
about tenant
Brewing
have you seen this
draft and you're you're good with this
you're good with this 1 amend coming
around okay so why don't you just tell
everybody why what's going on with this
and
yeah and and I just realized technically
we can't vote on it because we don't
have I don't have the
ls version of it but theoretically we
don't need it for the subcommittee we
can approve this and then and then take
it up to the full committee
so thank you chairman committee
members uh House Bill 1358 does several
things but as as the uh chairman briefly
explained one of the concepts on this
was to address the contract
manufacturing that is that is allowed in
the beverage manufacturing tiers so the
beverage manufacturing license the um
Brew Pub license and the Nano Brewery
license the first concept of this was to
expand that to the wine manufacturers
and the liquor
manufacturers contract brewing and
tenant room because we've had several
industry members uh in the past who
wanted to start up a business or they
have a recipe that they don't have the
equipment
for right so under the tenant
manufacturing concept they
would um with a tenant manufacturing
license go on to another existing wine
manufacturer or liquor manufacturer and
they would use their equipment to
produce their
product okay under the
contract manufacturing an existing
licensed manufacturer would enter into a
contract to
produce a product an alcoholic beverage
with
another lensey another existing
manufacturer right is the difference
between contract and tenant right so
this already exists for beer beverages
but it didn't exist for wine or liquor
this is expanding it out to include wine
and liquor in
it what it's also doing um and and a a
representative from uh Noble is here a
business a beverage manufacturer here in
New Hampshire and of course he could
testify
um to our discussions on this but uh for
a business model that wants
to bring a product product in from out
of
state right that is that is allowed
under a tenant
manufacturing
license to bring a product from another
state into our state in order to package
it the problem is that you're limited on
what products you can you can do that
for under the tenant Brewing license you
only can do it for beer and Specialty
Beer as the statute is written this
expands it out
to be available for products that you
currently are licensed to produce which
in this case for Noble's purposes would
include
cider okay so this is this bill expands
the contract Brewing the tenant Brewing
to tenant manufacturing and contract
manufacturing and
allows the um products to come into to
to be finished from out of
state
perfect any
questions it's rather technical
yeses this is the first time that we're
seeing the draft
correct but no we've had this bill we
had the bill we have the bill we had the
bill and the Brewers Association came in
with a bunch of recommended changes
remember this
did and they're not here does nobody
here they provided the Brewers
Association did provide testimony a
written testimony
okay no was it looks like this
it's okay yeah it looks B well do you
see that language in this build well
that's what I I this is the first I'm
looking at it so I'm wondering if
anything if we took any of their
advice some of that is addressed in here
one of the recommended changes from the
uh uh Brewers Association was using
instead of the term tenant manufacturing
using the terminology consistent with
the federal um regulations is
alternating
proprietorship which is an ALT industry
term referred to as alt prop under an
alternating proprietorship is the same
thing as the tenant
Brewer but
um we didn't adopt those changes in the
in the uh in the
amendment but there were also
suggestions you didn't take we did take
some of the suggestions yes okay well I
guess what I'm really concerned about is
you did give it a thorough good look
absolutely we've been working with all
industry um members on this Bill thank
you
yes
that term you used is alternating
proprietorship yes it's a Federal
Federal ttb Regulation they refer to it
as an alternating
proprietorship you thank you you're
welcome all right so given that we're so
but this so I'm this is your version
right what I'm what we're looking at
right it looks like our version so you
just would you make sure that the
beverage
manufacturers have okay to just to okay
certainly make sure they they're okay it
um
but just goes to show this is you know
liquor laws or mother mayi everything is
illegal
until somebody comes in and this is you
know when I was talking about how this
isn't the only guy you know nobl is the
only person who ever came in from out of
state and say gee I want to I want to do
this inside your state and so yeah and
we're trying to we're trying to solve a
couple of problems with this not just
the original request but it also um is
trying to to get clarify this the
difference between the tenant
manufacturer and also includes the wine
so and also and flavored malt beverage
right do we have the
other the espe especially beverage which
is the higher higher alcohol content so
that's we're trying to make sure we
cover everybody
represent thank you um I just got
confused because I'm looking at the
draft and it refers repeatedly to tenant
manufacturer uh and doesn't again I'm
just skimming over it uh since I hadn't
seen it before either uh but it doesn't
seem to refer to alternating
proprietorship so I'm confused whether
this is the same draft you're talking
about thank you representative in in in
yes the alternating proprietorship was a
recommendation that was made by the
Brewers Association right she's saying
she doesn't see that phrase in the bill
because we didn't put it in the
amendment we elected to continue to use
the tenant language which is
part of the title 13 our title so we
revie reviewed that recommendation but
decided not to accept it correct thank
you thank
you okay so we still need have an
amendment drawn up yep
okay all right that's enough for
today thank
you L have
amendments okay
yes so that way that way
I he's in the
room